this idea of mastery learning was always
kind of this gold standard this was
actually as a part of a fellowship I had
loves that MIT call the eller on to
fellowship to make a learning software
for students with ADHD and it
immediately struck a chord with me
because going into that the whole the
whole premise of the software that I was
working on was this idea that it's not
that students aren't capable of learning
some advanced mathematics or that the
topics are actually difficult it's more
that they just have gaps in their
knowledge and I did a lot of tutoring in
high school and I saw that over and over
again that the reason why students were
having my friends were having trouble
with algebra geometry it was just
because they had a gap in there negative
numbers or dividing decimals or
logarithms or whatever else
[Music]
good students start failing algebra all
of a sudden and start failing calculus
all of a sudden despite it being smart
despite having good teachers and it's
usually because they had these Swiss
cheese gaps that kept building
throughout their foundations now a lot
of skeptics might say well hey this is
all great philosophically this whole
idea of mastery based learning and it's
connection to mindset students taking
agency over their learning makes a lot
of sense but but but it seems
impractical
the real philosophical core of Khan
Academy is mastery learning and
everything we've built whether it's the
video library the articles we have the
70,000 items the game mechanics that we
have on our site it's all in service to
mastery learning
[Music]
you